[music]
>> Science and research are the corner stones
to bringing every country into the modern
world
>> I believe that there is a new opportunity
to provide education for all
>>Imagine a world where all the people work
together in harmony to complete an objective
geared to improving the quality of life for
millions of people.
>>Clergy is one thing, one concept, that could
end all wars.
[pause][music]
>>A world wide campaign against intolerance.
>>People are so prejudice against race, religion,
sexuality, [pause] it's ridiculous.
>>We need to produce power on a local level.
>>You have to look beyond the earth. You have
to look to space and get serious about it.
If you want to have a trillion human beings,
they aren't going to fit on the earth.
>>Tolerance.
>>When a man doesn't have a gun in his hand,
or a woman for the matter, he or she tries
harder to use his or her mind. A sense of
compassion and have intelligence to work out
a solution.
[music]